just how advanced were the ancient
egyptians
we all learned about ancient egypt back
when we were kids in junior high
but it turns out that there were many
fascinating details left out of the
curriculum that most people are just not
aware of
and i've discussed many of these bizarre
facts in prior videos
including that out of the countless
thousands of hieroglyphs and petroglyphs
in egypt
not one single one of them depicts
anything even remotely close to a
pyramid
which is weird in fact the pyramids are
so mysterious for the simple fact that
the egyptians left us with absolutely
no explanation whatsoever as to how
they constructed the pyramids and that
is indeed still a mystery
all we have today are theories and
guesswork
we were also taught that the pyramids
were built for the purpose of being
tombs for the pharaohs
yet not one single pyramid on the giza
plateau was ever found with a mummy
inside of it
true story google it it's just another
interesting fact that most people are
surprised when they hear for the first
time
and with these interesting facts comes
what is undoubtedly the most
hotly debated and controversial topic
amongst ancient history enthusiasts
which is
just how advanced were the ancient
egyptians
did they possess some type of lost
ancient advanced technology that helped
them cut
carve move and place millions of stone
blocks
or was it just a matter of sheer labor
by a bunch of guys wearing
towels for clothing but that is not what
this video is about
instead of us debating about a lost
ancient technology
let's shift our focus and discuss the
potential of lost advanced
knowledge that just shouldn't be
possible based on everything we thought
we knew about the dynastic egyptians
and this is why i am going to egypt next
month for the first time ever that's
right i am going for 15 days on a tour
and i'm going to all the notable sites
and i couldn't be more excited
this includes five special access
permission sites including two hours
alone inside the great pyramid of giza
as well as i'm even going down into the
animatic
osiris shaft which is three levels down
100 feet down into the limestone bedrock
on the giza plateau
i'm going to a number of places nearly
two dozen actually
and i'll be sharing more details about
that later in this video
but on the trip i will be taking
countless hd photos and 4k videos that
i'll be able to bring back and share
with all of you
so we can further explore the mysteries
of ancient egypt
but first let me get back to the topic
of this video
i was browsing through social media not
long ago and i came across a very
interesting post by a man named annie xt
who is a researcher who trained directly
under the late and legendary
john anthony west and what i saw caught
me by surprise as it's something that i
had never seen or heard of before
i of course was familiar with the
egyptian god men who was the god of
fertility
which it isn't hard to understand why
well
for obvious reasons and no pun intended
but i had previously seen different
depictions of men and various stonework
found throughout ancient egypt
including even small statue figurines
which let's be honest
stand out from other various egyptian
statues that are far more commonly seen
but annie xd's post which shows a very
unique depiction of men
that is different than any other look at
this
and think for yourself what does this
appear to show
it seems to me that that is a sperm cell
it is depicted in the middle of a stream
that is coming out of an erection from
man who again
was the egyptian god of fertility so if
you ask me
it couldn't be any more obvious that
this is indeed a sperm cell
which just shouldn't be possible for the
egyptians to have known
when this was carved in stone some 2 500
years ago
i mean is this not depicting a sperm
cell and
why on earth had i never seen or heard
of this before as again
none of the other depictions of men show
this unique and specific characteristic
have any of you seen or heard of this
before what are your thoughts leave a
comment
but let's be clear according to modern
historians and the scientific community
sperm cells were not discovered until
the 1600s in fact
the microscope itself was not discovered
or created invented i should say until
the late 1500s and
early 1600s yet somehow the egyptians
were apparently depicting
microscopic cellular biology thousands
of years ago
cells are of course the building blocks
of life and based on what i'm seeing
here
the egyptians knew that yet this is not
supposed to be possible
yet it's been hiding in plain sight for
all to see for thousands of years
again look at this and think for
yourself and then consider
that you need a microscope of a couple
hundred times magnification to see just
one individual sperm cell
at least to the point where you can make
out its shape and nature
even at 40 times magnification it just
isn't enough to make out the
characteristics
so again i ask how is this possible and
although i will say that microscopes are
not necessarily
advanced technology i mean they did
exist a few hundred years ago
but i would argue that the very thought
process going into wanting to study
something
on a cellular level is indeed advanced
thinking
at the minimum because again what we
were taught in school about the
egyptians
does not correlate with this i mean
again they're supposed to be wearing
towels and moving stone blocks for a
living right
but the study of something on a cellular
level
cellular biology is something else
i'm very curious to see what other
explanations people
have regarding this i'm sure some will
just may say it away
it will be interesting to see what the
deniers say about it but
at a minimum it is a fun and
thought-provoking conversation
and i i mean this is youtube so i can't
wait to see the comments section
i mean i can see it already oh yeah i'm
related to this guy
for sure absolutely i mean come on this
is combining the topic
of lost ancient technology or knowledge
with
large male you know don't let us down
internet
come on this this is potential to be
gold but in all seriousness
this depiction is significant how could
they possibly have known this
unless they were more advanced than what
we were taught in school and this has
been the argument on my channel
this whole time which is that clearly
when you study all the nuanced details
of the pyramid and other
various aspects and things sites found
in ancient egypt
it doesn't compute it doesn't add up to
the mainstream narrative
which by the way is far different than
even the narrative that
the local egyptians are taught and have
been told about for thousands of years
which is why i am going on a tour group
with the study of
chematology which is the people that
were known to have lived in egypt before
the ancient egyptians
most people are not aware that the
locals within egypt have their own set
of beliefs and it wasn't until
just a few hundred years ago that
outsiders invaded
and came up with their own theories most
people aren't aware of that either
but again i am not an expert which is
why i'm going to egypt finally to learn
and explore the mysteries of these
ancient sites and see it with my own
eyes and i couldn't be more excited
i'm going with ben from the awesome
youtube channel
uncharted x if you're not already
following him go to his channel right
now and hit the subscribe button
his videos are absolutely fantastic his
video editing abilities are next level
and honestly
i wouldn't be surprised if you see his
material and work on netflix someday
and he's been to egypt four times
already this will be his fifth visit
and he is toured with brian forrester
and graham hancock personally
and he is a wealth of knowledge so i
couldn't be more excited to go with him
and george howard is also coming on the
trip he's one of the scientists that
brought the initial evidence involving
the younger driest climate catastrophe
involving the carolina bays look him up
i couldn't be more excited
to meet him and chat it up because he
has a wealth of knowledge
and from what i understand he inspired
even some of graham hancock's work
directly but like i said i'm very
excited i even got my
indiana jones hat and everything and
yeah let's try that on
this bad boy is absolutely coming to
egypt i am freaking taking
a selfie in front of the great pyramid
with this bad boy on and
if you're not already following me on
instagram go and follow me there because
i actually announced this trip a few
weeks ago
and i'm going to be vlogging pretty much
every day
on the trip and just keeping you guys
informed at various sites and keeping
you guys posted
along the way but more details about
this trip
um 30 people all the spots have filled
up which is awesome
but a few people have had to cancel
looks like and a few people
others might have to as well because
it's 20 20. it's a crazy year for
traveling obviously so if you're
interested in going
uh it's first come first serve basis as
far as
uh signing up and and making your
deposit so you know if you're watching
this and you
have a desire to go to egypt from
november 28th through december 12th and
seeing these sites with me
ben and others in person look it up go
to chematology.com i'll put a link in
the description and you can also go to
ben's website uncharted x.com for more
details about the trip itself
but it's 15 days it includes a four
night
nile cruise river cruise which is gonna
be awesome apparently that's a highlight
for a lot of people that have gone
to egypt before it's all five-star
hotels
five-star food and uh it's gonna be you
know
good food cocktails and conspiracy
conjecture at night
should be a really good time and one
thing i mean obviously it's a two-week
trip so it's not cheap
especially with everything being
luxurious but it does include
amazing things such as the uh osiris
shaft
that in itself is a two thousand dollar
fee
uh and that's if you can even get
permission to go in and then they take
two thousand so going as a group you're
able to divide it up and get more bang
for you know out of it uh same thing
with two hours alone in the great
pyramid
and we're even going down onto the
grounds of the assyrian itself
uh abu wash abu asir and i think it's
five or six special access place so
it's awesome and i couldn't be more
excited um
what else is there oh here's another big
reason why i'm so excited to be going
even though it's a crazy year for
traveling
the opportunity here is huge because
tourism in egypt is dead many of these
sites are completely empty right now no
one's there
so there's never been a better time to
see and document these sites
on camera because usually if you've seen
anything in egypt involving video and
pictures it's just people everywhere
it's kind of like disneyland people from
all over the world but not right now so
that's one of the things i'm
very excited about is being able to
document this stuff and share with
everybody
with you when i come home but anyways so
i'm going to wrap this up i have two
other videos coming before i go on my
departure this video is going to be a
lot longer but i'm using a new
video editing software and it's a pain
to make a long video with something new
so look forward to that i have a couple
good ones coming and then i'll be
vlogging daily
on instagram while i'm on my trip so
again go follow me on instagram if
you're not already
go follow bennett on at uncharted x
and i'll leave it at that i'm jimmy my
channel is called bright insight
hit the like button and subscribe and
leave a comment share what your thoughts
are on everything discussing this i mean
is this
a sperm cell or not if you don't think
it is share what you think it is
but i'm telling you if there's anything
guys
the the ancient egyptians are far more
mysterious than most people realize
there's so many unanswered questions
involving how they did everything and
what
they knew and if you ask me this is
evidence
that at a minimum they were more
advanced than what we were taught in
school so it's a foundation for people
to start exploring and opening their
minds to what else is possible
involving our ancient past but i'll
leave it at that
you guys take care and have another
video coming soon bye everyone